THE NHL.
EVERY SHOT LOOKED LIKE IT
WOULD GO BLUE FRONT.
BERNIER -- SCORE! THE REESE.
BACK BY PAVEL ZACAC
REDIRECTION, SCORE ON THE
STICK OF MERCER.
HE IS TRYING TO BEAR DOWN.
RIGHT CREASE.
P.P.
>> SIEGENTHALER, HE GOT ON
THAT O BLOCKED.
MICHLAEA WENT DOWN AND THEN THE
TURNOVER UP HIGH.
STICK.
THAT IS STOPPED BY IN GOOD
POSITION.
THERE IS McLEO
OTHER NIGHTILS HAVE COME CLOSE
HERE.
NOT ABLE TO PUT IT OVER THE
SHARANGO AND UP AND
OUT OF PLAY.
>> I DIDN'T SEE IT.
I JUST HEARD GOAL.
DEVILS TAKE A 6-1 LEAD.VESEY HA.
PENGUINS -- HE GOT HIT
BERNIER.
SECOND TO THIS POWER SCORES!
HE AND ALMOST OUT.
MAKES THAT PLAY ALMOST ON THE
KAPANEN.
SIDNEY PASS FROMIN, ANOTHER BRE.
THERE.
SHOOTS.
STOPPED, BERNIER.
IN FRONT OF THE NET HERE.
PITTSBURGH.
OVER TO
THROUGH THIS PERIOD. TATAR KNOC.
THAT ONE.
AND SCORES.NDER.
JARRY IS ON THE ICE.
EMPTY NET, HE SCORES.
HE NEVER GOT TO THE TO GO
DEEP.
THEY DON'T MAKE THE CHANGE.
JARRY HAS TO